THE CROWD RISES AS ONE IN THE
BACKGROUND.
ROZIER, AROUND THE DEFENSE OF
LEONARD IN THE CORNER TO
McDANIELS FOR THREE.
NO.
REBOUND GOES TO GEORGE.
SHOT CLOCK IS TURNED OFF.
WE'RE TIED AT 117.
WALL.
WITH PLENTY OF TIME ON THE CLOCK
HERE.
PICKED UP BY ROZIER.
THEY GO TO LEONARD.
SIZING UP HIS DEFENDER, FIVE TO
SHOOT.
STEP BACK TO THE LEAD -- HOT
DAMN!
KAWHI LEONARD PUTS THE CLIPPERS
OUT IN FRONT BY TWO.
>> Jim: BRIAN YOU KNOW WHAT'S
INTERESTING ABOUT THAT PLAY?
PAUL GEORGE GAVE IT UP.
AND HE POINTED TO GET IT TO
KAWHI WHICH WHEN HE'S ROLLING HE
KEEPS THE BALL IN HIS HANDS,
ISOLATES UP FRONT.
BUT HE FELT AT THAT TIME, THIS
PARTICULAR TIME THE POSSESSION
THAT KAWHI HAD A BETTER OPTION